[Music]
good morning good afternoon and good
evening to you all and welcome to this
webinar on the future of predictive
genomics in israel
my name is francesco florindi i work at
thermo fisher scientific and today i
would be your moderator
predictive genomics was front and center
at the european society of human
genomics congress just a week ago in
vienna both the lenapaltonen award and
the esg award were awarded to
researchers performing research in
predictive genomics for the achievement
on
g was studies photogenic risk scores and
of course genotyping
so we have to ask is the predictive
genomics revolution finally starting the
path has never looked as as good as
rosie promising as as right now
but what needs to happen to really
implement predictive genomics in the in
the clinic in healthcare
today
we are blessed
with an international bundle of experts
to help us answer these questions with a
specific focus on addictive genomics in
israel
we will start with david uh setting the
scene on what is predictive genomics
uh zizes and saumia will help us to
understand the state of the art
and two crucial components of predictive
genomics biobanking and polygenic risk
scores
we will move then
to
understanding the specifics of the
israeli panorama with
our speakers
shy and uh of course
uh yield it
um
well uh the attendees you are more than
welcome to participate to the webinar by
submitting your questions for the panel
discussion that will happen at the end
of this
webinar uh please use the lab roots
interface to submit those questions we
will answer to as many questions as time
allows this webinar is recorded and will
be made available to you soon
and without further ado i'd like to
introduce now david hanna
our first speaker
david is
director
of business development at thermo fisher
scientific and he focuses on
our global market strategy in the
predictive genomics space
david the floor is yours
thank you francesco i want to thank the
meeting organizers for having me present
here
i'm the director of business development
at thermo fisher scientific
in the genetic sciences group and what i
wanted to first do
first start off is just sort of framing
the
the problem that predictive genomics is
designed to address
which is really around uh health care
spend ultimately
we have a problem with health care spend
globally in all all countries
with
what inflates those health care costs
are
spends on common diseases and the use of
medications with all inflate health care
costs and this next slide puts some
numbers to them so generally speaking
health care costs are about 10 percent
and increasing of the country's gdp
uh the amount that's spent over the next
10 years on dealing with common and
chronic diseases is pretty astronomical
showing this number 47 trillion dollars
and the adverse drug reactions using
mismatching medications to patients is a
leading cause of death in many countries
and all these things are inflating
health care costs so the idea is to move
to
a model in which we're actually
not uh caring for the sick but it's more
of a preventative care model in other
words we're managing health rather than
managing the disease so
you know the question is how how do we
do that and how does predictive genomics
play into that
well one thing we know is that
genetics is a large component of a
person a large contributor of a person's
overall health so we have environmental
social factors we've got lifestyle and
behavioral choices that that patients
make
and then of course a person's access to
clinical care but genetics has been
shown to be around 25 to 30 percent of a
contribution to a person's overall
health and if we can manage that
component better and understand what the
genetics component is telling us then it
will go a long way towards managing
energy and health
again rather than managing disease
so
it that's the question is how do we
leverage that information to improve
health outcomes that's that's really
what the holy grail is how to better
improve health outcomes the better the
longer we keep our populations healthy
the better will be able to manage costs
so
what i'd like everyone to do and this is
what i say to my children they ask me
you know what type of work i do is work
tell them to imagine a world in which
their children
might live in which is a sample as a
blood is taken at an early stage in life
that is the dna on that sample is
analyzed to assess a person's risk for
disease and we're really talking common
diseases i'll say more about that in a
moment and also a person's a risk for an
adverse drug reaction in which there's
some known
association between a gene and a drug
the information's pushed to the health
care providers pharmacists clinicians
specialists
and so forth and then that information
is used to inform a patient's how a
patient conducts themselves tests they
might take tests they uh might not take
actually if they have a low risk which
again that's another thing that inflates
health care costs is unneeded tests uh
but eventually we're resulting in better
health outcomes so that's that's that's
the world of the future and it's just a
matter of how how quick we're going to
get there right
so
what i want to say about uh two things
that we talked about
uh predicting uh
a a person's risk for common disease and
then an adverse drug reaction so
predicting common disease risks is
through something called polygenic risk
scores which you're going to hear a lot
more about today i want to contrast that
with monogenic diseases so these are
sort of rare inherited disorders some of
the earliest wins from the human genome
project the thing about monogenic
diseases is they're generally less
prevalent in the population what we're
trying to do is we're trying to tackle
common diseases these those polygenic
diseases
they're more common in the population so
if we can have it impact in that area um
then we
you know we've gone a long way towards
managing health care costs and just
keeping our population
as a whole
healthier so that's really what we're
targeting here is these complex diseases
so
as i mentioned
another portion of predictive genomics
the other side of it is predicting
adverse drug reactions so it's all about
predicting uh you know the future really
a patient's reaction in the future to
disease risk and to drug drug responses
it turns out that almost 3 million
people this date is from the united
states almost 3 million people have
adverse drug reactions it's 5 percent of
all hospital administrations and it's
one of the most common causes of
hospital deaths so the outcome that
we're looking for here is really a drug
that is both non-toxic and beneficial
there's you know three other
possibilities but that's that's the one
that we're looking for um and that's the
ability to predict that is becoming uh
actually is it's been known for several
for many years and more therapeutic
areas are
positively impacted by the ability to
make these types of predictions
a paper came out recently we call this
the kentucky teachers retirement system
paper the kentucky study
because this this
was an analysis of the return on the
investment of employing pharmacogenomics
in an actual setting this was a 32-month
uh trial that was done
and these bars just show that
during the latter stages of the
study
of the average monthly
uh medical savings was around 230
dollars per patient and cumulatively
this community cumulatively per patient
we see an increase in in the amount of
health care costs in general it's around
7 000 dollars per patient within that 32
month study that they did
this this was actually just published
back in in this past march and i
encourage everyone to look at it it's a
fairly landmark study that that's
showing that and i'll say more about
studies that are coming up in the future
as we move along here
so i want to now talk about
uh just taking a slice of where where
predictive genomics is happening
globally so this is a map of where
thermo fisher's engaged globally and
some of these studies are more focused
on uh
disease risk prediction some are more
focused on on pharmacogenomics or
exclusively focus on pharmacogenomics
and some are doing both
uh and examining both which is really
the holy grail of predictive genomics so
the one that you heard about about
earlier uh francesco mentioned it a lot
of uh there was a lot of notoriety at
the
eshg recently is that the fingens study
and what they're doing there this study
what's unique about it is it there's so
many stakeholders that were brought
together to uh make this happen it was
not only just the universities and
hospitals but actually pharmaceutical
companies and the idea here is is
you'll see a theme in the next few
slides you know to look for uh reliable
solutions for health care uh develop um
through the association with
pharmaceutical companies being able to
be able to develop therapies that are
more specialized for specific
specific genetic conditions which can be
predicted in advance and they used a an
array a microarray tailored specifically
to the finished population
again the goal is just prevent disease
prevention uh earlier diagnosis and
personalized treatments it's a
foundational study and it's been going
on for several years and they're
planning to renew it soon
another
a very large-scale study is one that's
occurring in taiwan the taiwan precision
medicine initiative this is genet
predictive genomics at its core because
this is also looking at
pharmacogenomics as well as disease risk
prediction right now there's about 15
medical centers that are involved and by
the end of this year they will have
enrolled up to a million patients
so they're eventually when they push the
data into the electronic health records
for for each of the hospitals and do you
know practice the model we've been
talking about been describing earlier so
it initially when they first got started
it was around 200 000 participants in a
few hospitals looking at a few diseases
ones that are kind of well known and and
it's kind of in a pilot phase but
eventually they want to get up to you
know basically the entire population of
taiwan and all hospitals and all common
diseases with the goal of being able to
maintain health in the population longer
a more focused study is at the
university of pittsburgh medical medical
center now this isn't actually gone
beyond the study stage and now they're
actually
implementing pharmacogenomics within the
medical system which is in the western
part of the state of pennsylvania
this again is focused on
pharmacogenomics the current state
they're a little bit beyond this now
this slide's a little bit dated where
they're just one main hospital in
pittsburgh and one or a few genes and a
thousand patients are now scaling this
up the idea is that collaborate the key
thing is a collaboration with in any
type of pharmacogenomic study you have
is collaboration with the pharmacist so
the clinicians collaborating with the
pharmacist and the patient put this
information electronic health records
cerner is what they use at uh upmc
and again matching the right drug at the
right dose at the right time for each
each of the patients
another study uh that this one has been
ongoing since 2013 2014
it's it's called the million veterans
project in the united states it's funded
by the us department of veteran affairs
so it's basically people that have been
in the military uh this is the closest
thing they have in the united states to
what we call a single-payer system
because it's a national uh hospital
system that includes research they the
thing that's unique in the united states
about this let's call it a cohort is
that they're very ethnically diverse so
they had to
be able to assess the genetics of a
diverse ethnic population here again the
goals are to be able to better manage
patients within the va the veterans
administration health system again it's
a national
a string of hospitals
but right now they're actually using
this data for some early clinical trials
both in cardiovascular diseases in which
they're trying to look at ways in which
they can put in interventions earlier
for people who have high risk according
to polygenic risk scores
another one is looking at prostate and
lung cancer being able to accelerate the
use of interventions new interventions
for patients that have high risk of
prostate and lung cancer usually the the
introduction of the more powerful
therapies is is introduced later but if
we know that a patient has a high risk
earlier on then they can accelerate the
use of the more powerful therapies
and therefore improve outcomes for the
patient
kaiser permanente is another study that
uh
is is new to the united states this is a
privately funded study
it's about 400 000 patients that have
been recruited again their project goals
are polygenic risk or pharmacogenomics
looking at actionable variants
it's really more of a pre-clinical study
to assess eventual implementation within
kaiser's health care system um and uh so
they're thinking in an advanced way this
is mostly uh centered in in california
now for time's sake i'm just to kind of
pass over to the last example and at the
nhs in scotland they're actually
implementing a clinical study right now
should call it it's an r d study for um
improved medication management and this
will eventually if the clinical trial
successful will result in implementation
of pharmacogenomics within the nhs
specifically in scotland
they will be using a microarray-based
assay and looking at sort of the
low-hanging fruit in the study which is
patients that are 65 or older on five
medications or more and hospital
hospitalized within the last year the
output of this is a report from a
company called corio life sciences which
is used it's developed by the pharmacist
and handed to the clinicians for
better management of these patients
so i don't want to go over too long on
time here but this is just a flavor of
what's that's happening globally and
what we mean by predictive genomics and
so hopefully this will cue up the nexus
speakers and go into more detail in
these in these areas
thank you
thank you david for this great
introduction and uh uh now that we know
what's predicted genomics we can
actually move forward to understand what
is the state of the art and for this we
have
our first international speaker uh this
is
is the head of the laboratory services
and biobanky at the
iarca which is part of the who in leon
is responsible for one of the largest
and most varied international
collections of clinical samples in the
world and he focuses on of course gene
environment interactions and disease
based collections uh a virologist by
a microbiologist by training this is
one of the most recognized and respected
voices in biobanking in in the world
former president of isbr
and uh of course he has an impressive
role of collaborations across the world
that you can find in the full biography
on the lab roots homepage
this is the floor is yours
thank you very much francesco and thank
you to the organizers for the
opportunity to
have a meaningful decision this is the
way in which
we're traveling this is certainly how
investments are going to happen within
the context of
healthcare provision whether it is a
private healthcare provision or
universal healthcare provision i think
the the road is going to lead us in a
very similar direction
so i'm going to talk about the state of
the art in biobanking and
biobanks are facilities that have been
created and have multiplied over the
last 10 years
to support the precision medicine vision
we need to move
away from the empirical medicine where
we provide one treatment for everybody
and move towards better targeted
treatments for specific individuals
at the right time that is evidence based
but
what are biobanks and the easiest
definition that we can provide is that
biobanks are facilities containing high
quality standardized
research ready and auditable material
and we don't only
consider the physical material just the
biological samples that they contain
equally the data that are linked to
those samples
as well as the legal and ethical aspects
of the governance of both the physical
and the digital side of the samples
over the last 20 years
the development of biobanking can be
summarized as follows
initially we had issues with scalability
so the focus was very very firmly on the
number of specimens can we actually
collect within a clinical setting
what we're anticipating what we're
needing
as high throughput
technologies and equipment were may
develop
and very quickly it was understood as in
many other fields and research that
we need to move away from these
situation where you put
rubbish in and rubbish comes out
the quality of the samples
and is of paramount importance and then
the quality of the data because we need
to start implementing or at least
thinking of using big data analytic
methodologies
and where we are now
we are at the stage where we are
focusing on the added value
of the collections what is stealing of
the data that we hold
but
we also have to deal with complexity
when we talk about
biobanks the number of
derivative
samples that we can get out of a single
physical sample has multiplied
the volume of data that we can get out
of
the analysis that we can perform on
these samples has really
really
so at the same time as we're saying okay
it's really good that we have these
facilities
able to feed into our high throughput
infrastructure in the different
hospitals
we also have to grapple with the
complexity that this technological
advance entails
one of the ways in which we
put a lot of emphasis in managing this
complexity and allowing the field to
progress
without actually having any
fragmentation
is by developing
a common language
if you like the
common language of
standards and guidelines that can be
implemented
and you can see here on the
slide summary of the last five years in
the development
of
biobank
so
ierc published the
common minimum technical standards and
protocols
for biobanks dedicated to cancer
research
so this is the
common denominator if you like the
lowest common denominator for biobanks
and then we had the best practices for
provide a
set of recommendations as to how
biobanks can improve
their
operations
the iso standard was published at the
end of 2018 started being implemented as
of 2019
we had
the bbmri eric academy come in
the qualification by repository signs by
isb coming in 2020 so this is
the side of killing the staff to be able
to respond and handle the needs that are
within this environment of standards
and leading all the way until
last year in this year to the
development of new courses
in low and middle income settings
so this is not an exercise that would
perform only for high income settings
technology
is improving the lives of every one of
us and has to be inclusive of all of us
so
what are
who are standards for we can take the
narrow view in terms of standards and
says it's only about the internal
process and the
product of that particular process
but um
[Music]
we know that
once we start implementing standards
this has a ripple effect
on the whole around those processes
so in the case of predictive medicine
the standard will go all the way to the
donor
relating to the way in which consent was
obtained the sample was obtained and
then treated all the way through to the
way the samples was released for the
research user
and
if we consider what the standards are
addressing again
we can have this very very narrow view
about the
quality relating to the process and the
product
but we know that
it it has a ripple effect on all the
processes that
somehow link
to
the biobanking that's
that's implementing this
standard so
personally i cannot emphasize enough
how important the quality of the
biological samples and the quality of
the data
is in terms of
the implementation within the predictive
genomics
field but um
also
the the situation that they will impact
all areas that relate to this type of
activity
um one last slide to say that this is
not
so
predictive genomics and biobanking and
the need to move forward with a more
effective healthcare provision is
attracting global attention and last
year we did present
some initial ideas at the un
general assembly science summit and we
hope to do the same this year
with updates
as to the progress achieved
i would like to thank you and pass on to
the next speaker thank you very much
thank you this is for your overview it's
always inspiring to see the high quality
work that you've been doing at
international level
and we keep the standard pretty high
with the next speaker so miyamotri she's
a senior policy analyst of the phd
foundation
her interest is in effective use of
scientific knowledge to improve the
health of individuals and populations as
well
she has a
extensive experience in policy
development for science and public
health and has contributed to a wide
range of phd projects including work on
personalized medicine whole genome
sequencing congenital disorder disorders
newborn screening
prenatal diagnosis and of course the
my favorite my personal favorite
work on polygenic risk scores that you
can find uh among the resources attached
to this webinar in the laboratory's
homepage
so go there and download it uh so mia
has a phd from
cambridge and masters in epidemiology
from the london school of hygiene and
tropical medicine
take it away
thank you very much francesco and thank
you to the organizers for the
opportunity to present here so i was
asked to talk about an international
perspective on polygenic scores i think
i'll give you a little bit but um
maybe others can give you a bit more of
a scientific background but i'll talk to
you maybe like francesca said a lot of
our work is thinking about the
nitty-gritty implementation issues so i
will hopefully take you through some of
those
before i start i just wanted to give you
a little bit of background about phd
foundation to set in context um some of
the work that we're talking about
so phd foundation is a health policy
think tank we have a focus on genomics
and related technologies and how they
can be used for better more personalized
health care we've been active since 1997
so this year is our 25th anniversary
year
and we
carry out a variety of work funded by
philanthropy grants and commissioned
work as well
the way we function
our aim is really to help policy makers
understand how new technologies could
improve health care and the actions
needed to put innovation into practice
we do this because we uh by
having a multidisciplinary team which
allows us to carry out expert assessment
of the scientific basis clinical
relevance and regulatory and social
implications of novel technologies we
also work together with a variety of
stakeholders including academics
clinicians decision makers within health
systems to try and explore some of the
issues and build consensus to create
robust uh health policy solutions and
we've been looking ahead to the future
of bioscience in a variety of areas
related to personalized medicine to
identify technologies and that can
enable more effective personalized
prediction prevention and treatment of
diseases and sort of this is the kind of
framework we've been applying to a lot
of our work and our thinking around
polygenic schools um as part of this
pathway to predictive genomics and
healthcare
so over the years we've done quite a lot
of our work quite a lot of work on risk
prediction and its implications for
health care and more recently since 2019
we've done quite a lot of deep deep dive
into polygenic scores and their
implications for healthcare pathways and
as francesco said a lot of our reports
are available freely on our website so
please do go and have a look
um before sort of coming here today i
did a quick snapshot of research that's
going on in the space of polygenic
scores and as david alluded there's a
lot of interest in using polygenic
scores to enable much better predictive
and prevention prevention of common
diseases and given that all the research
that's been sort of going on especially
over the past five years it's sort of
there's been quite a bit of a step
change in research in this area there
are quite a few trials i haven't listed
them all here this isn't by no means
comprehensive but there is quite a lot
going on in this space there's a lot of
trials within breast cancer both in the
um in the field of screening for
population screening as well as
improving risk assessment in familial
cancer clinics there are there's a lot
of interest in using polygenic scores to
improve risk prediction in the context
of cardiovascular disease as well as
other conditions such as melanoma
colorectal cancer prostate cancer and
there are a variety of initiatives such
as those mentioned by david and also
some listed here like our future health
which are really looking to understand
and unpick how we can best use this
novel biomarker as part of healthcare
pathways to improve
prevention and care for populations and
individuals
so a key question that we've been trying
to unpack and understand is really was
it whether it's clinically useful
uh to incorporate common susceptibility
varying information into prevention
programs for common diseases the value
and insight that we get from rare
variants as david said is well
recognized this is really thinking about
common variants and how to incorporate
that in and some of the questions that
can be broken down into are really
thinking through how accurately can
these genetic markers predict common
diseases does their incorporation into
risk prediction tools add value does
using this information lead to
improvements in current prevention
programs and pathways and if this is
better what are some of the
organizational ethical and social
implications that you need to have in
place
so these are some of the questions we've
been trying to unpack and understand and
our approach has been really to treat um
polygenic scores similar to other
biomarkers
uh and apply existing frameworks and
methodologies to evaluate polygenic
score analysis like other medical tests
this then allows us to understand the
state of the science and potential
implications for specific healthcare
pathways and then move towards more
responsible and effective implementation
and as i said this is really building on
a lot of work we've done historically
looking at evaluation of genetic tests
in the context of rare diseases so we've
been applying the same principles to
polygenic score analysis
and for those of you
some of you may be familiar with this
diagram on to my left here which shows
the ace framework which really covers
analytical validity clinical validity
and clinical utility as well as ethical
legal and social implications so this is
the kind of approach we've been adapting
and seeing how it fits in with analysis
of polygenic scores so that we can
better understand oh someone says they
can't hear
um
i'll just stop okay right so to better
understand some of the
implications for uh implementation so
and as many people will know for
evaluation purposes and for help to sort
of think about think through some of the
evidence requirements we really need to
place the disorder and setting um front
and center when we're thinking about any
application
based on polygenic scores
and it's really important to think about
linking the disorder setting and purpose
because it really allows you to then
think through some of the nitty-gritty
implementation issues and unpack these
and sort of put in place
some
sort of the best way to
implement these so for genetic tests
broadly we tend to differentiate between
an assay and a test we describe the
assay as a method for determining the
presence of presence or quantity of a
biomarker the re and the test as the use
of the assay within a specific disease
context in a particular population for a
particular purpose an evaluation of an
assay is very different to evaluation of
a test and the reason we make this
distinction is as many people and that
may be shy will tell you later on
polygenic scores are a technology and
you can use them in a variety of
contexts so they can provide in some
senses a sort of lead to a variety of
tests and each of these will have
different benefits and harms and so to
really understand and evaluate the
evidence base we need to understand
their tests on offer
the other sort of um angle to that is
that um polygenic scores are computed
there are a number of steps that require
to be in place in order to allow you to
get that information you need to have a
process for gathering genotype data
this could be either through using a
microchip microarrays or either through
next generation sequencing um as others
will tell you there are a variety of
models available across a variety of
diseases and so for health systems they
need to really be have a way of
identifying the best models to sort of
include in this pipeline and at the
moment models can be constructed in
different ways they've been validated to
different degrees and decision makers
our experience has been they're
struggling with selecting uh which model
they should select to take forward
um furthermore it's complicated by the
fact that models may be standalone or
integrated with other risk prediction
tools and to give much more what we call
integrated risk prediction taking into
consideration other risk factors
and then there are issues around how do
you
communicate this information to
healthcare professionals
as well as patients for decision making
so by understanding the how analysis
might work in practice what's fed back
we can really unpick um what needs to be
in place to make sure we move towards
implementation
and it's also really important for
evaluation they're quite interlinked
because to demonstrate utility which is
really think about what value this kind
of information adds to a particular
pathway we really need to understand how
it might be regulated
in addition to how it might be evaluated
and one of the bottlenecks for novel
assays and tests such as polygenic
scores is that it's been quite a
challenge to identify the nature quality
and quantity of evidence required to
ensure safety safe and effective safety
and effectiveness to place a test in on
the market
and also to place it within a particular
healthcare pathway and also as
you may or may not
realize the regulatory environment
around such devices ie risk prediction
tools is quite dynamic at the moment and
if we do want to move towards this
predictive and personalized model of
care we need to have there have a good
understanding of how we can get through
sort of this dynamic environment
so some of the key conclusions um that
we've sort of come to are that
apologetic schools can be useful
uh some of the key conclusions that
we've come to about polygenic scores can
be a useful buy mark and have potential
utility we're very enthusiastic about
them but we feel that we really need to
we're at the point now that we need to
understand this um test on offer and its
intended purpose to make a judgment on
utility and really go towards developing
the evidence base for each potential
application within a specified care
pathway and if we need a better
understanding of these parameters such
as analytical validity clinical validity
and utility and what it's possible to
get through existing research and what
that's contributing to
our knowledge base so that we can work
with policy makers and other decision
makers as well as patients to make them
understand some of the known loans and
uncertainties around use of this novel
technology
and i think what we have said
consistently is that there's quite a lot
of emphasis on looking at polygenic
school models this is not sufficient
reason for implementation when we are
now and i think that the stage is
shifting a lot of people are moving
towards thinking about implementation
and what how the test will look and how
we can think about how these function in
real life settings
i'm just going to end quickly by saying
thanks to our team which is
multidisciplinary as well as a lot of
people that we consult in order to
inform our recommendations and ideas in
the sphere and just to say that if
anyone's interested in speaking to us
about this and sort of having some
discussions about it we're more than
open to hearing your views
and thank you very much
thank you uh samia uh for your wonderful
analysis uh very very clear very precise
um it is now time to move uh straight
into say the main focus of our webinar
today which is israel and to understand
how predicted genomics can be
implemented in the country
um
uh i welcome you did cohen back um
here
judit is the scientific director of
midgam
the israel national biobank for research
she has a bachelor degree in biology
with a master in clinical biochemistry
and phd molecular genomics
capital by a postdoc in research in
cancer so a
great background
which repaired of course with managing
the institutional tissue bank at the
sheba medical center before joining mid
gun
yeah with it the floor is yours and
thank you very much for being here
thank you very much and francesco and
everyone
um
well i will talk about uh
israeli national biobank for research as
a research enabler and actually
all what was discussed prior
can be done with samples that we have
samples and data as this is mentioned
and that we have in our biobank and i'll
go through briefly about how you what
how we work and how you can uh use our
facility
um well this is our team
um
we are
okay i'll go through the hierarchy later
i will just say in few words very
briefly
uh that
the role of
biobank's biobanking worldwide is
extensively important and i won't go in
details but you can see that there are
so many
um
research works that were done using
biosamples
and
um
drugs were
or the benefit of patients
um
and
regarding the operating model that i
also will go briefly i will just say
that um
we have a board of directors led by
professor chihanover which is a nobel
laureate and
responsible mainly
for policies and
recommendations that we need to do and
steering committee and we also have a
scientific committee that helps us
deciding things that
arise occasionally and we are con um
we are
have five different uh hospitals medical
centers that are part of midgame and
um
the management is responsible for all
aspects
of day-to-day
and it goes through operational aspects
and scientifical aspects
and all the computational aspects
dealing with the data and stuff
regulatory aspects which i will mention
uh later and of course budget marketing
collaborations
everything that we we believe that needs
to be
done
so i will go through our vision briefly
well midgam is an hebrew word for
samples but it is also acronyms for
uh israel national biobank for research
but it's in hebrew
and anyway so we are in a national
infrastructure actually we are also a
governmental uh infrastructure
and and our vision is to promote
personalized medicine for the health and
welfare of israel's residents
and we want to as as such we want to
provide an added value and growth engine
for the high-tech industry research
institutions and healthcare
organizations
in israel
um
i will say a few words about creation of
a virtuous cycle and i will maybe i will
start um
okay i will say that everything is
focused about quality of healthcare and
i will start maybe with the uh with
budget and the financial support and
well
budget needs to be allocated
for biobanking in order to make sure
that the most relevant biosamples are
being banked
and
one cannot use human bias samples
without
uh ethical approval so this is going now
to the third part uh and once we have
everything
achieved r d
is in motion and uh when a study is
successful publications will enable
receiving more budgets so this is the
way we're um
making biobanking better and research
better
and and that that way we can support
healthcare quality
okay
well i will not elaborate too much about
types of biobanks i will just say that
there are many kinds of biobanks and we
are
um
a type that is disease oriented and
project-proven we are focused mainly on
cancer but not only
and
i will i want to say a few words about
our goals
um
well by providing human uh biosamples
we are and
we are an advanced uh platform for the
biomedical research to promote
collaborations
between medical centers academia and
industry nationally and internationally
so one word that is very important is
collaboration and improvement and we
also accelerate proteomic genomic and
molecular scientific discoveries in
cancer and other diseases by collecting
high quality and well annotated
human biosamples we enable the use the
usage of national resources to develop
novel diagnostic tools and biomarkers
novel drugs for targeted therapy and the
use of newest research technologies for
personalized medicine
while talking about personalized
medicine um
as one of our main goal i want to remind
us two quotes one of hippocrates that
was mentioned before
by david i think in a way
well he said it's far more important to
know what person the disease has than
what disease the person has
um and also you said something about
this is from the european union uh
definition of personal medicine
that we need to provide the right
treatment to the right patient at the
right dose at the right time so i think
if we're doing these we are okay
so how can biobanks um
in general and midgum specifically can
support personalized medicine
well this this is and i like this uh
um slide because it's
it has everything in it
um
so
we are going from
you know when when we say personalized
medicine we mean for for a group of
individuals who suffer from a specific
condition
there are few few general alternatives
but what was done up till now is uh
more
what is called empirical
medicine that
that means
in general that one treatment fits all
for example
in cancer uh chemotherapy is the first
line uh and it's evident based and it's
worked it's working
but there are some patients that don't
benefit from this treatment and when we
try to sort them according to specific
criteria uh such as specific markers
and then that it's called stratified um
medicine
so you know all the blue people will get
uh something that is relevant according
to the markers or or uh
a gene that was found which is good but
it's not good enough so a higher level
of therapy is personalized medicine
where
the off-road treatment is based on a
patient's unique molecular markers
and that goes for the polygenic score
risk score that was discussed before and
will be discussed later on
um
i will give you one example so if
there was a drug that was developed for
a specific um
indication of certain indications
according to molecular marker it could
be used
for another patient with
a different indication but has maybe
that has maybe the similar uh
characteristics molecular
characteristics
so performing researches uh on biobank
samples is a great way to give an
optimal answer to the last two options
the stratified and the personalized
medicine groups
um
okay
we collect
a process and preserve the following
biosamples we have tissues
tumors and normal
fresh viable fresh frozen and paraffin
embedded we have blood from healthy and
treated donors
we have
healthy tissues
may be collected from donors which go
through different kinds of procedures
maybe mammoplasty or earlier or
something like that but
most healthy
samples we have from
our blood samples we also have other
samples and many controls and i want to
emphasize at this
webinar that we recently obtained a
large cohort of dna samples from various
diseases not only oncological diseases
that can be used
for research by the scientific committee
both in israel and outside and you can
talk to me later if you want to use it
okay
um our guidelines are strict
regarding the
collected samples we never
collect samples at the expense of
patients
we must ensure that the diagnosis and
continued treatment are not impaired
this is
a major and important
guideline
this is also something that this is
this is was talking about before um and
i can say that
some years ago friends of mine danielle
dubois and peter watson published this
article
um
uh that is
talking about the development of of
about the bad ethnic field i will not go
into details i just wanted to emphasize
that the evolution
and trends uh in this
field are
as this is says before i am developing
so at the early days uh biobanking was
all about quantity and and quality later
it was mostly about sustainability and
the needs uh that were projected by the
different stakeholders
and
and by that biobanks became smaller and
more focused
and in my opinion
um
i
think that
the next step actually the current uh
stage and that is that bow banks
that fit to purple
um this is uh our
website you can go
and
visit us
and we have all the relevant data
collected
presented there and this we have a
database database software called data
plus uh that where we keep all the
information
uh regarding the samples themselves and
the data
of the donors
and i want to say a few words about
ethic
ethics and regulations because it's
really
a crucial part of a proper management
especially for biobanks
so
we have an irb approval for collecting
as i said processing and preserving
biosamples for every future study we
have an informed consent form which is
one page
that is suitable for all kinds of
studies it enables commercial
use
of the samples collected it allows
withdrawal at any time
and regarding return of results
we can discuss it it's an an issue that
needs to be discussed maybe later
uh i want to
think i have it here um i want to
emphasize
uh
that samples from edgama provided only
after a designated study was approved by
a local irb
uh sorry
and we at midgame enable distribution of
biosamples to every approval israel
study that means if you are not from
israel and you want to have samples from
us you can do that but we will help you
uh submit your proposal to
uh to the uh irb in israel with us it
must have an israeli approval
um
well i think
that's
that's what i want to say here and
there's
um
a short list of uh publications derived
from studies uh of leading researchers
who have published and continue to
publish in scientific literature with a
high impact factor that have used
samples from exam
um
in addition we are in contact with
dozens of researchers in israel and
abroad including a large ongoing study
with the nih
and actually i think we'll go through
the bottom line that i wanted to share
with you
um
please remember that we are a national
and approved platform that promotes
research in various fields in israel and
around the world that deals with
understanding mechanisms involving
cancer and other diseases
development of various diagnostic tools
develop development of new treatments
use of modern technologies in custom
medicine and in short
we have samples and data you need for
your studies
finally
i would like to
express my gratitude actually to the
donors
who generously gave their bio samples
and data to be used in biomedical
research for the benefit of future
generations we are obligated to keep
their confidentiality and we will do our
best to make their donation valuable i
would also like to thank the ministries
of health economics science and the
technology and the professional teams of
the various medical centers
um
and
if you have
questions
later on but you can keep the contact
details and call us whenever you need
thank you very much
thank you so much you did
very inspiring to see the great work
you've done and also to understand that
the ministry is backing you up and is
making the right investments to further
personalize medicine in general
and you know wonderful for you to remind
of the real
protagonists here which are the patients
and citizens we're all serving
um
the next speaker will
be welcome the next speaker will join us
virtually more virtually than the rest
because unfortunately shai could not be
with us today but he pre-recorded his
presentation um shaikh army is the
associate professor of the ibr
university of jerusalem school of public
health
he has an undergraduate degree in
physics and computer science and a phd
in physics from bar elan university
on top of a postdoc from colombia
he researched
of course population statistics and
medical genetics
his group
the shakarmi lab focuses on developing
and applying computational methods for
identifying the genetic basis of disease
for genetic testing and risk prediction
progenicus course and for studying the
demography of population based on
genetic variation so thanks
income to matcha
shai for your presentation and i ask
the team to kick-start his presentation
okay hello my name is shaikh army i'm a
statistical geneticist and a population
geneticist at the hebrew university
and in this talk i will describe recent
studies
um on the evaluation of polygenic scores
in the israeli populations
uh so polygenic scores were
should have been explained in a previous
uh talk in this webinar so i'll just go
over it briefly
and we will
this course are using summary statistics
from genome-wide association studies for
various uh
traits and diseases in order to predict
the trait or for the risk
of new individuals and the way pollution
scores are constructed is using this uh
simple equation where um
the polygenic score of an individual is
the sum of the number of risk alleles or
trait increasing alleles
carried by an individual and so gi is
the number of effect alleles at a snip
which can be zero one or or two and beta
hat is the estimated effect size
uh
of that allele
um so this is the main idea and then
there are there are many methods that
were developed in recent years to er
select the set of snips for inclusion in
the
polygenic score either as the set of
genome y significant snips or old snaps
or some other methods and also our
methods to refine
the risk estimates
but overall this is the basic idea
so
i will now talk about uh ways uh in
which we measure the performance
of polygenic scores for first for traits
and then for diseases so i show here a
list of a few uh
traits that are commonly studied
and uh for each trait i show you here
some like the range of estimates
for eight squared this is the
irritability this is uh broadly speaking
the proportion of variance in the trait
that is explained
by genetic factors
um
as you can see it's uh up to eighty
percent for height around fifty percent
for bmi and so on and r squared is the
way we measure the performance of the
polygenic score is the proportion of
variance in the trait that is explained
by the polygenic score
as you can see for all traits of course
r squared must be less than the
irritability we cannot explain
more than the total readability and
typically we explain much less
typically the typical numbers are around
five to 15 percent
um except for height that is the best
studied trade so far where the best
scores now explain up to up to 40
of the
variance in height
for diseases the situation is more
tricky we cannot
talk about the variance diseases are
binary individual can be either affected
or unaffected so it makes less sense to
talk about the variance in the disease
status so instead we're talking about
the variance in the liability so the
liability is a
so what is the liability it is assumed
that even binary diseases they have an
underlying continuous
liability we cannot observe this
liability we cannot measure it but it
but the ability is a representation of
the predisposition of the individual to
the disease and all the individuals that
have limitability
above certain threshold
are affected as you can see in this uh
diagram here
so
so we measure the performance of the
polygenic score for a disease as the
proportion of variance in liability
explained by the score
um which is typically five to ten
percent for a
most commonly studied diseases with uh
relatively large genome-wide association
studies uh perhaps more familiar indexes
are
an index for uh
binary diseases is the auc area under
the caribous index for a time to event
and then to measure the
performance of footaging score
many studies also look at the odds ratio
when comparing individuals at the top
let's say five percent or one percent or
ten percent uh of the distribution of
the polygamy score in the population
comparing to all others or the
bottom a few percentiles and also
another popular measure is the
odds ratio
comparing
individuals
who have prs at the one standard
deviation above the mean
relative to the mean so these are uh
common ways to measure the performance
of polygenic scores for diseases and
what i will show in the rest of the talk
uh i will
describe
a study some by by
by my group and some by others
that measured the performance of
polygenic scores um in the various
israeli sub-populations particularly
focusing on ashkenazi jews
which is the largest population
so uh so we know that uh polygenic score
accuracy
is lower in population that are not
european so for example this is
a distribution of r squared values for
trades
relative to europeans we can see that
performance decreases in particular for
a african population
but the question is what can we say
about the populations of israel as i
said earlier particular
ashkenazi jews
so
um uh
first i will uh describe results for uh
for traits for height in ashkenazi jews
uh from a study and that we published a
few years ago
in the context of a screening of ivf
embryos
in that study we also looked at the the
accuracy of the scores for height
first in a cohort
of hundred couples from new york and
then also in a cohort of
about 30 very large nuclear families uh
from israel and uh interestingly we see
that the performance is about the same
in both courts where the budgeting score
for height explains about a quarter
of the variance in the trade which is
comparable to
a
divergence explained in courts of
individuals of european ancestry uh
using the score that we used at the time
um so now um moving on to diseases uh
one disease that is of most interest in
ashkenazi jews is crohn's disease
because it has a somewhat higher
prevalence in that population so this is
a study
from the mount sinai biobank in in new
york where they evaluated the accuracy
of a number of budgeting scores
as you can see here different ways to
compute the scores based on different
association studies and they evaluated
the score
using auc in uh european hispanic
african-american and ashkenazi jewish
population and as you can see here not
only that the score uh
accuracy
uh does not diminish in in ashkenazi
jews aj here as compared to europeans it
is actually even slightly higher
so this is very encouraging um
in terms of like the ability to predict
a risk in the ashkenazi population
and we studied
schizophrenia
using an israeli cohort
of about 2500 individuals
and in a recent
study we found that the variance in
liability explained by the score is uh
about seven percent uh which is again
comparable to the
uh
variance explained that was seen in
course of european ancestry
the mount sinai biobank has been very
useful for evaluation of the accuracy of
this core in ashkenazi jews because of
the
largest ashkenazi population in new york
uh
and in the in that recent paper
a
bell by natal evaluated a polygenic
score
across multiple diseases in the
non-ashkenazi
individuals from the mount sinai uk
mount sinai biobank
and here you can see results for three
diseases showing the prevalence of the
disease
versus the prs decile and you can see
again a comparable very similar
performance of the polygenic score in
between ashkenazi and non-skinazi
participants
in a recent study we did a systematic
evaluation of
the accuracy of polygenic scores
across multiple populations including
kashinasi
in the uk biobank
so
using
principal components analysis we were
able to identify about 1700 ashkenazi
individuals in the uk
biobank and we evaluated the predictive
uh of producing scores across over 200
traits and compare the accuracy
and to the accuracy scene in individuals
that were
born in the united kingdom the results
for ashkenazi jews are here showing that
uh accuracy in ashkenazis is about 86
compared to individuals with british
ancestry so this is comparable to what
we see here for italians
um
and is a higher even much higher than
what we see in other populations for
example
individuals from india or
east asia or africa and individuals so
again all of these results so far
show
relatively high accuracy of religion
scores
in the ashkenazi population uh almost
comparable to what is seen in the
individuals of european ancestry
um so now in the i would like to show a
couple slides
uh
moving beyond the ashkenazi population
uh and also studying individuals of
other ancestries in israel and
unfortunately there are not to so many
studies so i will just show you what we
have right now uh so this is an
unpublished study from
my lab showing results of the study of
age-related macular degeneration amd
from a nasa medical center in jerusalem
and here
the participants came from all israeli
sub populations about half of them were
ashkenazi the rest were jewish not
inaudible
for a
amd works quite well even this more
diverse population uh in the bottom
fifth of the population in terms of the
risk score and
we see only 35 percent of the cases
compared to 86 percent
um
sorry thought that fifth of the publish
and the fifth in the bottom fifth of the
cohort uh about 35 percent are cases
here compared to 86 percent uh in the
top fifth individuals at the highest
a risk or in our cohort
now
in terms of
non-jewish populations there is uh
really barely any data out there i'm
only aware of one study
by our group also in collaboration with
the team at lassa medical center
uh where we studied
cholesterol levels in a muslim village
in which there is high prevalence of
familiar hypercholesterolemia
and
after we adjusted for uh
the pathogenic variant that is common in
this population we looked at the ldl
cholesterol level versus the polygenic
score and we see
correlation
which was statistically significant but
the correlation was very modest um it
could have been because the score was
relatively old the score that we used at
the study uh but it could also be that
uh the score is simply not as predictive
in this population we don't know yet and
um unfortunately uh right now to the
best of my knowledge there is no
uh additional data about the accuracy of
polygenic course in the
uh muslim populations of or non-jewish
population general
of israel
so uh to conclude uh
based on uh multiple studies i think we
can now say with some confidence that
polygenic scores that are
computed based on genome-wide
association studies in europeans have a
relatively high accuracy in ashkenazi
jews almost the same as observed in
europeans and this is based on both
anecdotal studies as well as systematic
evaluations across multiple cohorts and
also across
three countries israel
united states and the united kingdom
we have very little data on the accuracy
of purging scores in
other jewish subpopulations and
non-jewish israeli populations um
and hopefully this will change
in the future although this may be
progress may be slow
moving forward
there are a couple small projects
underway that i'm
involved in
for studying breast cancer and coronary
artery disease
in hospitals in israel
um
but
perhaps more promising are two large
projects uh
that are
at the different stages one is the 10k
project of the weizmann institute
and that that will collect or is already
collecting a
genetic and frantic data and the second
project is the the first project of the
ministry of health that
in the future will collect
a genetic and phenotypic data on tens of
thousands of israelis and
thereby will provide more information on
the accuracy of
risk prediction in the knowledge kinesi
populations of israel
thank you for listening
thank you again shai uh
if you can hear us i know he has lessons
today to attend um but his presentation
was really excellent in providing again
more background on israel i'm asking all
the uh speakers to uh join me uh on
camera
for the panel um thanks again for your
outstanding insight
um
and uh i want to remind all the uh
attendees that they can still send
questions for us to answer we got some
interesting ones already um
from the uh from the attendees so thanks
for being active
um i will kick start with an easy one
uh quotation marks very very not so easy
i would say
um
what what really needs to happen uh we
understand now the uh situation in
israel we understand what's the state of
the art what are the obstacles what
needs to happen to unlock the potential
of predictive genomics
in um um
in israel and uh
i would like to
start from you
right um what needs to happen
well uh i guess
first of all we need to have awareness
that for all the possibilities
uh that
biobanks exist and midgum especially as
a national
entity
is here to help and provide
the samples needed for whatever research
is uh is
on place is in place
um
but i also think that i'm not sure it's
relevant only in israel but we need to
maybe
try to lower costs of sequencing
and
make
bureaucracy maybe easier i think
midgum
can help
reducing time uh for to to get those uh
um approval needed
um
there is a lot of
issues concerning um
what you do with the results i mean
um you get many
many
results that are treatable and some that
are not and how to
how to deal with that i was referring to
that in the presentation i said uh
return of results like it's it's nothing
but it's an issue that needs to be
discussed
um
i think a lot of uh
um
i mean you you can divide the the things
that need to be done into the practical
things uh deal with the bureaucracy deal
with the costs and stuff like that but
on the other hand is more maybe more um
community things is is the awareness of
the possibilities
and francesco if i may
israel is
not unique in that sense
in that
during the pandemic we've seen
the benefit of being able to connect
dots in moving research forward
and we need to get into the
mentality of a lot of our funders and a
lot of our
um
stakeholders that this is not
only something we do during an emergency
situation this is something we should
pursue as a matter of routine practice
before david i wanted to bring in so me
as well because we we mentioned the you
know getting into the mind of the policy
makers and i i know very few
experts in this field who managed to
communicate with policymakers as well as
so mia did
can you can you want your perspective on
this
i think we lost samia
but in that case david please go ahead
no i just i think that showing uh
[Music]
you know a path and and what the
benefits might look like is key i think
that was just said a moment ago and i
just want to add to that is that um
pilot programs need to be funded in
order to
demonstrate utility in order to because
it's it's a complicated workflow uh the
most of the technologies are exist for
doing this and the reporting structures
are
mostly crafted it's really putting all
the parts together and implementing a
program
and predictive genomics
or predictive medicine whatever you want
to call it is is is
involves so many working parts so it
needs to be it's sort of like baby steps
uh
small pilot programs need to be put in
place in which the entire workflow is
demonstrated and then
the key stakeholders will understand
what
what components need more attention more
resources and then scaled up from there
so it's really just
moving from a discussion this is a
theoretical to actually
uh piloting small programs of you know
maybe 10 000 samples or so and these
need to be funded
and then uh and this could come from a
collective funding from the the various
stakeholders and then scaling up from
there it's it's just because of the
complexity of doing something
that's so um you know uh groundbreaking
and um pioneering um that's
in my view that how things need to get
started
thanks david um so i now i see that
samia she's back so
i'll move now to her
uh we heard from david that you know
funding pilots would be the key uh we
need to explain this to policymakers um
what would be your opinion on this uh
samia
i'm sorry i um missed the question
because my computer glitched um
the panel believes that predicted
genomics is the way forward we but we
need to lower the costs make bureaucracy
easier raise awareness and speak the
language of the decision makers the
funders to make them understand that the
value of
funding
studies that can put together the
existing evidence
you are the closest you are the one who
actually managed to translate this whole
problem
in my opinion the best to the policy
makers so far
uh what would be your suggestion to uh
further the the field
i think one of the issues that we've
consistently um um sort of experienced
in this is that there's sometimes a bit
of a disconnect between researchers
policy makers and end users of whatever
application there is
there are different levels of
understanding i mean there isn't a
shared understanding of the evidence
needs at different levels there's a
different unders they might not they may
not be content experts they may not
understand particular
things such as polygenic scores you know
there's we have experience especially
with polygenic scores the sort of
conflation with rare variants and we've
had to do quite a lot of work to sort of
get rid of that misconception so that
people can understand it and think about
it as any other biomarker and when to
say to them actually you don't have to
be as
in some senses the evidence sort of
balance that your risk benefits are very
different
and so it's there is quite i think one
of the key things you can do is actually
there's a lot of bringing together these
different stakeholders
to achieve some consensus on evidence
needs because i think ins definitely you
can sort of almost lower your threshold
of evidence needs for example you don't
need rct for every single application i
think and you have to really understand
where the research how far the research
can get you and be comfortable really
that it can get you to a certain point
and after that you have to just try it
out and have processes in place like you
say to feed back into the loop
another thing i i want to also add is
that
what we've seen is
sorry just a larger appetite for um
pharmacogenomics just because of the the
proof points that was just mentioned a
second ago are are mostly there
um whereas the polygenic risk score as
as a let's say biomarker is uh kind of
on the vanguard of being pushed in is a
clinical
thing uh whereas pharmacogenomics it's
more of a well-traveled
area and for groups that are wanting to
get into
you know predictive genomics it seems
like what we've seen is that they're
prioritizing uh frequently
pharmacogenomics is a is a test bed for
you know
the connection between the patient
physician and this in that case
pharmacist so just that's just a trend
that we've seen
thermo fisher
i totally agree with you david i think
both um
everything is about money eventually so
you we need to to decide where the
society need to decide where we put the
money
uh either in the personalized medicine
specifically
[Music]
uh individuals or we we take something
that we can help
more than one
or
uh a large cohort so this is you know
it's it's a balance between those two um
and these these are the stakeholders
that needs to decide where you put the
money in
and the other thing i wanted to say that
as a biobanker i can say that
the data that comes with the sample not
for the sample itself this is kind of
easy but this the clinical data that
arrives with the sample
is
so important and this has also many
problems with the harmonization of data
but it's not only the data that come
with the sample at the time of
collection it must follow with the
sample with a donor for i don't know for
as long as possible and then you can
make
the
um
conclusions of any research much more
uh
thick and would be much more important
and can be useful for for the benefit of
other other patients and not only the
donors themselves so this is also
something that needs to be considered
make a great point you did and uh right
now i'd like to bring in shai uh who
actually uh answered some of these
questions earlier uh and uh i think he
makes a very you know interesting point
um
on exactly on the issue of data
particularly in israel
uh so the hmos i already mentioned but
beyond uh the fact that healthcare that
everyone is covered in just one of those
four hmos the hmos also have
a longitudinal electronic medical
records going back 20 to 30 years and
very detailed and very rich and this can
be
these are great for research and uh
these records can be can be used to
validate project risk scores uh
and implement them and and and
follow up the patient so this is a
really uh fantastic and
could accelerate the implementation of
predictive genomics
um i think in the israeli population uh
generally speaking there is a
willingness to get tested there is also
a interest in the genetic testing and we
see that in
the program for a preconception genetic
screening which is a
a very common in israel and there is a
very
high rate of uptake of this testing and
same for prenatal genetic testing
so this is probably going to be
accepted by the population once
once it's offered by the healthcare
providers
on the other end weaknesses of a
a
or i mean the the difficulties that we
are going to have towards the
implementation of
predictive genomics in israel is the
little data that we have on the
knowledge kinase population
and and also the current legal system
which makes it uh somewhat difficult to
conduct genetic studies
in
in israel in particular in the in the
academia
uh so we heard from uh uh shy that
indeed the healthcare record system he
mentioned the hmos
you know the specific uh healthcare
system uh you have in israel uh led by
several insurance companies that's a
very ripe environment where you can
really connect a lot of the data that
you yell that you you were mentioning
before
what what do you think about the
the
willingness of people to actually
share their information
so i can add that
we we made a short uh
questionnaire
in israel uh
regarding this
willingness
to not to share the data well also to
share the data but the main question was
um are you willing to to
to donate samples share data and receive
back information
so uh from
around half of the people that were
asked
were willing to to donate samples and
from them 40 percent wanted to get back
results and were willing to share
whatever is needed along the way um
so i think in general once you decided
as a patient or a donor or
okay i don't like the word patience in
this context but as a donor you decided
that you want to donate your samples so
uh almost uh 40 percent uh will would
like to to share their data and would
like to get back the results for their
own and and to
to get that benefit out of their their
donation
thank you very much
um we're approaching the end of our uh
webinar uh i'd like to ask one of the
questions that actually we got from the
audience uh on developing countries
so the question comes from muhammad
moidin
in rawalpindi and he's curious to
understand what's the panel opinion
about implementing precision medicine
and predictive genomics in developing
country now this is clearly not the case
of israel but we know that a lot of
developing countries are looking at
israel and europe as as examples uh for
you know for the future of their
homework systems this is i would like to
come first to you and then to to somia
and the whole part
yes absolutely um
[Music]
i'm in agreement with what you said i
think israel can serve as a blueprint
for
how things should be done because we've
had experiences
of
actions that have worked very well in
actions that have worked less well
uh in the past and even in the recent
past
i
i think the
the
what we want to avoid is technology
becoming yet another
differentiating or discriminating factor
when it comes to low middle income
settings
there are
examples that we can use
say from israel in developing
infrastructures that serve as a
central
[Music]
center of excellence
and
cover
a particular part of the population
but do it very well and
that can be an example then you can use
to roll out
to
the remaining population
within that particular geographic area
so working from something small and
well-defined that works very well and
then expanded as as time goes on
so i'd say actually there's two specific
angles one like z said i agree there is
looking to learn about infrastructure
and looking from other countries and how
you set this up broadly speaking a lot
of developing countries have a very
different system healthcare systems that
they have to develop something that's
specific to theirs there's also some
consideration around the underlying
science and the data and what it can
tell you and how it can apply to these
populations because as we know there's a
lot of lack of
diversity in genetic studies so i think
as of june 2021 86 of genetic studies
were in european populations and so we
really need to understand what a lot of
this
information means for other countries
and other populations even studies that
have been carried out in
african-americans are not completely
transferable to those for in africa but
you know there are efforts on the way to
improve this and i think they will um
sort of help develop such systems but it
is i think there's an opportunity that i
think definitely predictive genomics
personalized medicine is
applicable to all countries everywhere
you just have to sit look at how it fits
in with emerging systems and how best to
integrate it in
thank you so much samia um
uh we're really really close um
uh at this time um i think that uh we
don't have time to answer all the
questions but
thanks again to all of uh all of those
who um submitted questions uh our time
is up
i would like to thank you first and
foremost our speakers for your time your
expertise for sharing your invaluable
insight into predictive genomics
i also like to thank the team who
actually made it uh
put all this wonderful webinar together
as i said this is recorded it will be
available online for you to share with
your colleagues
and your teams very soon
this is actually predictive genomics
week
within thermo fisher i feel later today
we have another webinar on the more
technical aspects of delivering
predictive genomics focused on uh on
really the the difference between the
different technologies you can use to do
predictive genomics
um you can find the webinar on lab roots
uh just search for creative genomics or
thermo fisher and you'll find it
finally you might also be interested in
the next country focus on predictive
genomics we'll look at what qatar is
doing on the 28th of june again on lab
rules so you can use the search engine
within the system to find it out
and please don't hesitate to reach out
to myself to the team and of course to
the speakers via the lab roots
contact form or by
you